الدبابات في اوكرانيا خطوه اعتبرتها بعض
الدول حلا ذهبيا للاقتراب منفرجه الحرب مع
روسيا والبعض الاخر لم يراها الا ضجه غير
كافيه لتغيير مجرى الحرب حيث كتب الصحفيين
جوليان بارز واريكشميت في صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان الدبابات الغربيه في اوكرانيا
وعلى الرغم من الضجه حولها الا انها لن
تمكن من الانتصار على موسكو دون تكثيف
الدعم الامريكي بالبرامج التدريبيه على
استخدام الدبابات
والمدرعات والذخائر المتطوره لضمان قدره
الجيش الاوكراني على الانتفاع من المعدات
العسكريه الغربيه
فارس وشمعه اوضح ايضا في مقاله الصحه ان
المساعدات العسكريه الجديده لاوكرانيا
تشكل توازن دقيقا للبيت الابيض والنيته
بين رغبتهم في دعم زنسكي وعدم استفزاز
بوتين بما يصعد القتال لحرب او سعر